hey everyone welcome back to another
video you are about to watch my first
chess games of 2022.
i hosted a nine round swiss viewer
tournament and actually uploaded the
first game of that tournament in the
most recent video the staff organic game
you can watch here in this video you'll
see my next eight games had a lot of fun
and exciting moments a lot of fun
openings gonna time stamp every game in
the video description feel free to hop
around and watch what piques your
interest and also watch to see if i can
stay undefeated
in the first day of 2022
so i do hope you enjoy the video don't
forget to like and subscribe
and enjoy some chess
one of my goals this year is to try
playing new openings
um
let's play c3 delayed elephant
yeah bishop
d7 probably not the best move
not a blunder but
the main line is knight f6 to target the
pawn
so here i'm happy just to take over the
center
question from corrupted foxt
what openings to study as a new player
if you're a new player or like pretty
new to the game
um
just knowing basic principles and
tactics will get you further than
learning specific openings
but i recommend if if you want to like
look into the world of openings
choose e4 and d4 both are playable
and then learn something against e4 and
d4 from black
but
yeah don't go overboard
i want to target f7
this might just win a pawn actually
queen b3
although it leaves d4 undefended so
queen b3 e6 takes on b7 i lose d4
so i think i'll play bishop e3 over
defending the pawn
preparing this move
although now if i try and win b7 there's
rook be eight possibilities
so
a6 hmm
um
queen b3 e6 queen b7
some weird knight a5
i'm taking a bit of time here
i also have knight g5
e6 queen f3
to play hyper aggressively
knight g5 e6 queen f3 knight f6
e5 takes 94.
i don't think that does much
another line i'm looking at is
queen b3 e6 d5 then knight a5
i was hoping to target the b6 square
okay i think i'll just castle i spent
way too long there
trying to look for
cool ideas
this position might just call for the
slow and steady
gradual build up
just enjoy the space advantage
prevent black from
ah did i blender upon i allowed this to
black maybe had a chance to win e4
okay i'll play bishop c2
or can i play e5 here
e5 we trade
yeah e5 looks more appetizing
because there's no knight e7
bishops bishop should really be on b7
and now the knight has to choose between
this square or the square or b4
although b4 loses a piece
if not here i think i trapped the knight
i'll start with knight d5
oh no my pawn
so the point
is if black takes i have this move
i think i still have this move
oh i also have this move
i'm probably even stronger
hitting the bishop and hitting the rook
and now
okay the bishop and rook are attacked
there is this move
but now i have this move
i think i'm winning material here
i'm just invading the holes of black's
position
are there any players with higher rating
than you i can check between rounds
i don't recall seeing
anyone over 2600
it's possible there's there's still time
to late join
question from spinning siri what's your
big plans for 2022
[Music]
well the first plan uh at least this
month is to
play in gibraltar
playing the gibraltar battle of the
sexes starts january 24th
it'll be my
first classical tournament in a while
[Music]
and my first like invitational
norm tournament in a long time
so we do have the gibraltar command
with more info
okay so i'm maybe not winning material
forget about 97
i play a4
a4 looks nice
black is really pinned down here because
i'm pinning the bishop to the queen
and putting the knight to the rook
this knight's restricted by the pawn
also the knight can't move here because
it cuts off the rook from defending the
bishop
rook's also tied down
as bishops also dominated by this pawn
oh maybe i can put black and zigzang
eventually
wow
i want to play this move because if
takes i fork
i was thinking rook b7
[Music]
a5 and then takes i could take with
queen
[Music]
i could also
oh wow i can take here because if takes
i
i take the bishop and i fork the rooks
and threaten maybe 906 maybe not
rook d5 is covered let's do this
and the beautiful thing is if pawn digs
i play rook
a8 attacking from all directions
oh thank you happy danny for the bits
okay
i'm playing uh
boy aksha
who i think subbed earlier
i just realized my opponent
yeah even if my opponent is watching
and has listened to all of my ideas it's
hard to stop
what's coming
wow
so now the queen is essentially trapped
i mean things can move
i think most likely the night moves when
i win the rook or when the exchange
hey it's gary happy new year gary
hope the
year is getting off to a good start for
you
okay knight c8
oh this position is too much fun
i could take the rook but i feel like my
bishop is stronger than the rook
i play this move
and try and
oh i don't have any time
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i'm having too much fun
[Music]
okay i'll take the rook
if i take the bishop
we could just simplify
i'm going to let black breathe a little
bit
okay 7 looks nice here
okay we can trade queens
oh my knight's a little bit misplaced
play this move
up the exchange
if rook d3 i play rook c8
play f4 first
kudos to my opponent for fighting on
from what looked to be a really bad
position earlier
okay
finally making some way to win more
material
hey botezza's daddy gifting five
thanks so much
i gotta stay focused
basically have to average two seconds
per move
oh i'm actually threatening maiden two
now
oh no my pawn
okay upper rook
funny move this move
it takes i check and win the rook
i still not i still have not had a
checkmate this year
one one flag and one resignation good
game though
that was a fun game
position got really passive for black
in the early middle game
ah
okay
the second staffer gambit maybe
of 2022
hey let's go
what if for the rest of the year
every time i'm black i go into a staffer
gambit
that'll be my exclusive opening so here
we have a staffer gambit declined
this is not as trappy as like
the normal stafford but
it's uh it's objectively better for
black
there's queen here
i know there's also f5
maybe f5 first
thank you spooky cats
subbing for three months
yeah so i want to complete development
i'm not sure which way i'm gonna castle
yet
but this is a nice construction
[Music]
you see force playable
i think it makes sense to take
oh there's actually a funny line
so takes takes
takes takes takes takes check and i win
the queen
i could also take on d4 actually
maybe that's just better
bring on d4 there's bishop takes
i take back queen takes takes
and then takes
uh it gets spicy
yeah maybe knight d4 is not the the move
and c4 it's such a
it looks like a very punishable move
you just have to
discipline myself here so takes takes
x takes takes cause i don't see what to
do after
take on g7 because rook's hit and rookie
one's a threat
i could take here first
if queen takes end knight d4
if pawn takes
that should be good somehow
let's do that
i'm actually looking at a funny line
pawn digs and then knight d4
oh no my knight but then after takes
takes takes again if takes bishop h2
and if
takes takes takes takes bishop e2
[Music]
i'd imagine there's some compensation
hey it's blender prone gifting five
thank you blunderprone
okay this was the initial thought
in this line
so i went upon i attacked the knight
i always have to be careful because the
king is a little bit
a little bit of a sitting duck in the
center
queen d1
[Music]
i kind of want to take here now
happy new year okay
maybe you're working
and your position is pleasant in 2022.
thanks so much for zoom
that's very kind
yeah having some funny lines so far
[Music]
opponents debating which thing to take
oh no my knight
yeah again if uh queen takes knight
there was a bit of h2
but now my e pawns are a little bit weak
i want to do this but then takes and i
lose my knight
oh there's a funny line okay i'll castle
wait a minute
oh i calculated the wrong thing
i just got using queenie seven rook here
castle
and the funny line was takes queen f7 oh
no my knight then i mate
ah
i played the wrong move in my
calculation
now b7 okay it's still a good position i
think
there's lingering ideas of this and this
knight c3 is a normal move
i want to play this
check here takes
i think i'll go for it even though i
don't see a clear
oh wait a minute
i'm threatening maiden three here
opponent defense i was sending queen f2
followed by rookie one
i'm sorry things ready to attack
hey thank you thank you
and sharing your knowledge you deserve
all the support oh that's so kind thanks
so much
i want to play knight f3
cool idea
ah how'd you do this
f7
maybe rookie five
i'm taking time here because it looks
like there should be
i'm seeing another funny line
oh wow look at this move c6
not the first move that comes to mind
i'm i'm beating the queen to take the
pawn
there's really not too many other moves
for whites
queen a5 looks really wrong
oh queen g5 i completely forgot about
okay after the game i'll have to show
the line i was looking at
i forgot about queen g5
okay i'll take
oh i'm off a pawn here
when did i win a pawn
oh this whole thing in the center
okay
and white never took my
hanging pawns
develop the king
white was threatening to take and check
him in the night
it's not a good habit getting so low on
time
but now
now i'm forced to play quickly
i'll take and play bishop b6
even play this move
oh this is nice
making the king move away from defending
the rook so then the pawn will be pinned
and then i can take here
i might lose a piece back after rookie
one
but i'll probably win another pawn
also depends where the king moves
yeah so rookie one
maybe i would be tricky to play knight
g3
now let's take
okay up two pawns white has this move
running the triple fork
i really gotta watch my time
i should have moved back
there's a trap rookie seven and then
this move
okay going after the b-pawn
if check i probably play king h6
or maybe this
[Music]
move gain a little bit of time
my king is short on squares
that's a good move
play this move
i'm only up of han
i was turning into a good fight
maybe should have taken that pawn
now we have an end game
okay threatening this system meat
let's be careful here
defend
this is a really good fight
that's a great move
almost fog there
okay now i'm winning white how to draw
there
the rig h2
this is a really close
game oh wow
rotation shoe would have been a draw
well played
here's to another year of great chess
content
oh thank you caveman slovey
now last game was a bit shaky but i'm
i'm thankful to have
three out of three next round starts in
10 seconds
good morning to irene
good evening to everyone
everyone in north america
but yeah good morning to
europe and asia
okay let's play
play an english opening how about
mix up the openings a little bit
so i'm still undefeated in 2022
we'll see if i can keep it up
oh it's 3am in spain
yeah it's
8 18 am for me
i'm playing this is actually the same
position i had in round two
of the rapid tournament i played in in
dubai
this can be a very dangerous opening if
black doesn't know what they're doing
my dubai game went uh bishop e7 bishop
b5 bishop six
knight e4
black got under serious pressure
bishop d6
probably a slightly better move
it's still tempting to play this a b5
i'll play bishop b5
my idea to play knight e4 knight g5
one of the knights to g5
yeah it's still not too late to join
just have to join before round five
and nice thing is with knight e4 i
pressure the bishop
have these ideas but i also unleash the
queen
and now hitting the knight twice
if knight ce7 i can play this move
running mate
hmm
f5
calling my bluff
f5 is interesting
i kind of want to play this knight to g5
although that might backfire
maybe i just go for this
okay so bishop's hanging maybe when the
pawn on c6
okay now
this diagonal looks very exploitable
but the question is how to exploit it
because i want to play like queen b3 97
[Music]
ah okay i'll play bishop c4
that's a nice line knight e7 e4 and if
takes takes i attack the knight and
threaten mate
and knight f6 is uh has a move black
wants to play
but it's not legal because
the knight's pinned
yeah so here we see uh
just how the english opening can be very
very aggressive
14 move win with english
okay i also feel good game
yeah it was basically a reverse open
sicilian
but extra tempo gave me
gave me enough to
really maximize the pressure against
black
was there i'm on another game oh wow two
rooks versus one rook
wait what happened to the rook
ah
i lost a rook
what happened in this game
oh no
i pushed the pawn
i was probably dreaming of making a
third rook
this end game it's generally just a
theoretical win for black
you should be able to use the two rooks
to there's a ladder and eventually force
a trade
no what happened
oh no
oh there's big reading disparity too
[Music]
oh that was subham
alabama against prakrie
good job subham for the persistence
how did i win that
white won this game that's crazy
it goes to show it's never over until
it's over especially in blitz
thank you java fellow gifting to
lockheed asking is it normal
or wait i play worse on my phone
francisco once again also quack
oh hello from
hello from st louis
hello to san francisco
let's play a knight's tango
yeah i think it it is uh it is a thing
like
people sometimes will play worse on
their phones
just because the
board is smaller it's easier to slip
i like the feel of playing on a desktop
where i have a mouse and
i think it's a bit
a bit harder to be careless when playing
with a mouse rather than
just using your fingers on the phone
okay so night's tango
it's mingling
video
i see her oh yeah
but mainly quack
mainly quack i appreciate that
i see the comment from frog
yeah it's possible you didn't join
properly but if you click the join
button
you have to join the team and then join
the tournament
um
also with swiss sometimes if you join
late and you have zero points
if there's an odd number then the person
the very bottom
will have a what's called a buy
and that could have happened
i also know like some people play better
on their phones too
[Music]
because it can be easier to move quickly
thank you non-seasonal
[Music]
okay so we have a typical king's indian
structure
r4 might be coming
debating how to
try and plan ahead in this position
does this move
it's like the natural continuation but
it's restricted by the g3 pawn
[Music]
but maybe i want to play it because f4 i
take take your creates
target the e file
another option is to play c6
and just leave some tension so then f4 i
have queen here
when the b-pawn
i think i'll play c6
i'll switch back to the
the standard
because i don't want the music to put me
to sleep
but i was using the
the pentatonic sound setting on the
chest
it's a setting where the moves in the
game generate music
okay knight d3
i mean one plan is to go for f5
i could really just slow play
throw in queen b6
a queen b6 why not active square for the
queen
yeah generally the bishop will stay back
because there's not a great place to
develop to like bishop g4
[Music]
it could get kicked around
and the purpose of it will be maybe
someday to support f5 maybe support
knight g4
there could be a cool move coming queen
d4
hitting all the things
i could walk into knight f3 though
if i take on e4 there's knight f takes
e5
wow c5
i'll admit i kind of missed that move
but maybe
ah knight c4 is coming
[Music]
yeah c5 is probably really strong
[Music]
so how bad is this
if i take knight here
queen b5
i lose e5
but then i win the d-pawn
let's do it
if d6 i play knight g6
if knight e5 i take on d5
if 96 here
queen a5
i guess there's knight
d takes e5 defending the d pawn
but then after takes takes
and the bishop and queen are tied down
to the pawn
knight e5's tie down to 9 c4
yeah the position is really opening up
probably
i guess if we go into this line takes
takes takes rook d8
getting a third attacker
if d6 i don't think that scares me
also gaining a decent amount of time
here
almost up a minute
i have a dream of putting a knight on d4
in nice outpost square
yeah white spending a lot of time here
yeah there's multiple options to
consider
so i was expecting this rook t8
this is why it's uh especially in blitz
it's really important to
calculate on the opponent's time
knight g6
so this is what we call superfluous
knights
sometimes they can be a good thing
but sometimes they can be awkward
[Music]
like the knights are kind of tied down
to defending each other
i'd like to play this move soon
thank you i christy inc
sobbing with prime
at first it looks kind of good for white
because the knights are active
pawn has passed but
i think it's very delicate
it's like a cookie that's about to
crumble
and it's going to be
filled with chocolate chips
i'm gonna enjoy the sweetness
maybe f5
hmm
i could also take
and then win the pawn
i mean i'm hungrier for more than just a
pawn
but if f5 queen c2
a pawn's good enough
one of the drawbacks for white is this
structure
makes my bishop very uh excited
i win the b-pawn too
[Music]
debating whether to take right away or
take on d1 first
i guess i'll take right away
making sure my back rank is okay
b7 is covered there is rook b1
rook b1 maybe bishop d5
and queen d3
okay i'll take on e3
b7 is hanging
queen or rook can take
probably rook t8
anything better
i'm thinking here but then queen c7
and then rook beats the threats
so i might play rook f8 here it looks
really passive
but i think it's called for
very close to winning on time
i want to play this move when i lose a
queen
so maybe
there's c4
just opening the diagonal
h6
just making some luft
i want to play this
attacking and pinning from behind
okay
a reasonably solid game
um
yes e5 it uh i thought it was strong at
first but
i guess it was still
a bit tricky even for white
c5
ah so it is a top move
or one of the top moves
but the game keeps going knight c4
[Music]
it just became very imbalanced
the d6 was a mistake overextending a bit
too much
apparently 93 and white's okay
or rookie one even
okay
actor tournament
11 games going
one game going ooh
theoretical end game
oh the black's going this way
wait no black's going this way ooh
can white win this
this is an end game that everyone should
know
white's having some trouble
how long have they been doing this
so a3 was played on move 67
i don't want to say anything too
revealing because
always could be a chance that
one of the players are watching
so we'll watch and enjoy the show
what's going to happen
[Music]
is white going to win
is black in a draw
is black going to win
and how will the game end
checkmate flagging resignation
threefold repetition 50 move rule
someone disconnects or rage quits
offer draw
[Music]
how else can games end
oh stalemate
yeah white's i'm still meeting the king
there
i did give a lecture on this exact
endgame
in one of my earliest st louis chess
club lectures
it was called end games everyone should
know
or end games you must know
let's see if i can find it
oh maybe it's this one
important end games
that people mess up
as we're seeing here
oh what just happened
oh i missed it slow motion replay
wow so what black queen
white oh no
oh no
black one
i was not expecting
black to win that
anyway for people that want the lecture
uh
here
it starts around 30 minutes link is now
in the chat
unfortunately i don't have time to
explain it now but
in the lecture i explain it
oh playing simple simpson i think this
is the second highest rated player in
the tournament
okay king's pawn
[Music]
let's play
play a spanish how about
a royal lopez oh i don't want to play
berlin
i don't know what to play in superman d3
bishop c5
i should know what to playing against
berlin but
um
yeah i'm not like a super booked up
spanish player so
i'll just try and play normal moves
and get some position i can work with
so d6 d4 looks interesting
i play d4 it takes takes
usually before knight c3 takes
castling
i kind of want to do it
i also have bishop d2
[Music]
play d4
this is where my lack of knowledge could
bite me
that's also where my adventurous opening
play can maybe pay off
it's already a bit against principle to
have played d3 and then d4
okay black's losing time as well
[Music]
yeah i was thinking knight c3
this reminds me of a like molar attack
gioco piano
i'll play this move
thank you zela404
[Music]
oh the link to the endgame video i'll
share it once more
is there
i gave that lecture before i was active
with my own youtube channel
it was back in probably early 2017.
so d5 could be a threat
another idea is just to take and
then try and target the c file
probably don't want to take too soon
though
i don't think that knight is going
places
we might see bishop d7
i'm trying to stay flexible because
there's a case where my bishop just
drops back and
centralizes
and here i probably just don't want to
trade
although bishop d3 knight here and then
knight f4
hmm
there's also okay bishop d3 knight g6 e5
also just take and queen cease the two
hit the c pawn c6
rookie one knight g6 knight f4 happy new
year
the four knight g3
yeah that's pretty low risk
pretty solid
oh thank you resilient happy new year
also thank you headless subbing for
seven months
yeah we're both going to have knights
that are
trying to defend and attack
our respective king sides
and the big difference in this position
is a structure
i have more space
but
maybe these pawns could be potential
targets
but for time being i'm defending them
pretty
pretty thoroughly
so d5
so calculating e5 knight e4 knight g3 f5
on passant
d5 is interesting
wait a minute one more time e5 knight e4
knight g3 f5 ambassador
i think
black would have to take with knight
it might be knight g3 there but then
so i take with knight 95 we trade looks
pretty good
because we could also trade on g3 here
so if we trade on g3 then this line is
completely restricted
ah so
95 we trade knight g4 thing f2
i have f3 knight h6
some potential minority attack
also potential for e6
yeah let's go for this
every trade i just got a nice pass pawn
in the center
i don't think black has too many options
here
my opponent might be considering this
move
which looks weird but
now what to do with the knight
knight g4 f3
i also have rookie two
i also have e6
few moves to consider here
i'm thinking e6 first actually
oh but then queen d695 i lose h2
just so i chased the knight to a useful
square
maybe rookie two
isn't so simple actually
i guess f3
you get ready to minority attack
there is a small trick in the position
i'm hoping black stumbles into
[Music]
because a natural looking move for black
here is a blunder
yeah if knight f5 i would have had e6
but now the f5 is prevented
only wants to play this
maybe this move
trying to tie down the rook and
threading this
and trying to discourage this but i
might be encouraging it
so queen b6 maybe a4 knight f5 a5 we
trade
we get a rook ending where b7 could be
weak
i could get a foreign
a very it's going to be a long kind of
tense positional battle
it's nice black can't play a5 here
because
i've been the queen
i think a5
queen c7 i take
i actually could take with a rook
but probably better to take with pawn
realizing e6 might fall a knight f7
e5 the knight f7 e6 knight g5 e7
so i'll have to go for counter play
against the pawn
rook f7
okay rook clearly wants to be on the b
file
probably this move
supporting f4 preparing the double up
yeah probably f4
g5 there's knight h5
the nice thing is i'm ready to play this
a rook d7 coming
uh
this move
i5 g4 knight here h3
i think it's okay
there's g5 in the end
making f2 first
getting ready for g4
let's start with this
96 i've taken would be seven
yeah here i just wing connect four
now they move quicker
um i don't know what to do
[Music]
in this move
wow
wow look at this these pawns
are marching
oh i can't take i can't push
it takes its mate
wow
oh it's such a weird nate
i think black's doing okay if not king
takes e5
but that was a pretty intense game
i mean we both got very low on time
i was not expecting the king to get made
in the center of this game
this is advantage of double pawns
they kind of create this wall
yeah all my things were necessary for
the mate
because my king could be elsewhere
in this pawn but most things were
necessary
good game
okay
staying undefeated
okay probably playing uh one of these
people
i guess i i'm committing to this promise
so far
of playing the stafford
oh no staff for this game
i was like going to play oh just a
normal
bishop's opening
the move yeah the move i generally like
to play is knight a5
i'm going to remove the join command
from the chat or from the stream title
[Music]
join command will still link to the
tournament but
um
yeah too late to join
hey my opponents from planet earth
that's good to know
not any other planets
bishop g5
most people play this or this
so bishop g5
i think i'll just play bishop b7
i could take but
don't have to take right away
sometimes i like leaving the tension
because
it can
[Music]
provoke the opponent to think a bit more
okay phone's moving quickly
yeah here i'm just going for a solid
setup
wait a minute can i no i can't do that
i always have to consider this when
there's tension
the problem is knight takes and it
defends
c6 is pretty standard
i have the bishop hair
c6 not only restricts the knight but
also prepares d5
to try and open the position
oh of all the lines to calculate
i think i should probably start by
taking
the first thing that came to mind was
this and this but
i don't think it works
yeah i'll take
i'm looking at the line knight takes h6
bishop h4 knight never mind
queen b3
i mean our queen b6 doesn't do much
because bishop e3
what to do here
another thought is this move prepare f5
i think i'll always start with this
love to
remove white slash bishop
i don't think i need to worry about a7
i'm gonna play f5
looks a little bit wrong
i leave the bishop yeah f5 there's 94.
i can't get too carried away
another idea is h6 bishop g5
another idea is
d5 e5 c5
i think i'll play h6
just go for some
[Music]
i don't even know if this trade benefits
me
i just want to trade queens because i
feel a bit cramped
there's not much to do and white's about
to expand
there's a line knight d4 i still play
bishop g5 we trade
we trade everything
even trade rooks
i have to leave my rook on eight
the end game looks playable
now even though i feel the cramped
it's also questioned what white is doing
in the position
at least i have a clear plan
[Music]
maybe white's considering this move
takes takes takes knight g7 rook f3 i'm
bishop
g5 the korean barbecue was so good but i
am going to regret it i think i think so
much are you getting the meat sweats oh
no you need sweat american quack quack
quack oh no my stomach quack
i hope you feel better
i hope it was somewhat worth it too
[Music]
okay
i think i'm going for this
going to trade a lot of things
like potentially both bishops
queens rooks
it's possible have rook and knight
versus rook and knight
oh i could take here first
the problem is after takes takes
takes takes i lose a seven
it's someone else getting merch and
donating ten dollars
items for
54.90 including oh no my queen
chessboard is sleeve tea and donated ten
dollars
i appreciate whoever that was
okay of
[Music]
oh i have to take with king actually
yeah cause my queen signed down to
defending
oh
wait this is interesting
so there's queen f2
attacking
two far away things
and then i would play king g8
and then if it takes takes rook takes i
can take
so it takes takes
takes takes takes i have queen c1 in the
end
queen c2 with check
ah but my queen here stays on d8
okay but this line i have takes takes c5
and d4 of b5 b6 i think
gotta try it
okay so the goal is to make this bishop
regard its life decisions
i'm trying to conceptualize how i trap
the bishop
it's not so easy
like queen a5 bishop b8
i might as well start with this
thank you the black goose
eric
geese love blueberries um blueberries
wait really
okay so i'm threatening the bishop
here i'm also threatening
horsemate
which i'll try and not reveal too soon
i welcome back the black goose
yeah i think queen a5 and queen eight
would have been very similar though
queen a there's knight b5
and my queen would maybe regret its life
decision
[Music]
i'm realizing there is a move here for
white so maybe
try and survive
oh there's a funny line
so i was thinking h4
but i still check queen f1 bishop b3
with king h2 bishop f4 king h3
oh we might go into it
i'm not done calculating though
so queen
at the very least i win the bishop
the point is to provoke the king to h2
put the bishop where it's defended
and now i have a choice between taking
free food
or going for the
[Music]
ultimate dessert
or maybe starting with this move
and then
defer my decision
mmm
it's the ultimate dessert
okay
oh that was a feel-good game as bishop
couldn't really re-enter
okay
that was around seven
[Music]
it seemed like i was close to getting
outplayed there
but i think white's
stepped in a little bit too deep
and the bishop kind of walked into
quicksand
although the engine still says this is
equal
wait c5
ah queen f3
so there's a few moves to like be okay
it's actually crazy why can play g3
allow queen a5
and then bishop b8 i can't win the
bishop
but sometimes the engine doesn't reflect
like how tricky it can be to play for
one side
okay
let's go back to tournament
you're probably playing the funny yeah
funny d4 man
let's play e4
and be less funny
yeah i usually play this
let's go into it open sicilian
i was playing what i usually
i usually play queen c7 and not bishop
e4
so yeah this is a
this is probably a playable line
knight b5 comes to mind is
an option
just trying to target the
d6 square
i'm also wondering if i can take and
play this
i'll play knight p5
my new year's resolution stop eating
chocolate chips straight from the bag
it's not going well already also quack
yeah you should put them in a bowl first
and then eat them
or
[Music]
oranges don't buy chocolate chips
and they're harder to consume
okay i have to
take yeah this is actually a like
decently well-known line
um
what do we call it
i forget if i even like ever learned the
name of this opening
but the main moves to take
and
it doesn't look great for black because
black will have an isolated pawn
and i'm the one with the bishop hair
in a pretty open position
however i believe this line has been
played like even the top levels
the black has nights more space
i know the engine will give like
a slight advantage to white
probably bishop f4
yeah after h6 i don't really know
any theory
but
i think i have a decent understanding
where the pieces should go
ah spanish duck say qua
okay rookie one it's 4 30 in barcelona
so i will stop gambeting my sleep
[Music]
[Music]
luego
okay want to put the other rook in the
center
yeah this feels very very cozy
really nothing to worry about
and yeah it's going to be difficult for
black to find active play
like generally when you have the isolate
queens pawn
you want to like activate the minor
pieces
but 94 is
restricted maybe d4 is possible but then
knight e2
queen d7
i still move the rook in
wow h5
so now i'm very tempted to just pin the
knight
and i'm taking advantage of the fact
that pawns can't move backwards
and now the queen
if it moves up
i'm happy to take and
go in for the kill
this is also the drawback of black not
having a dark spot bishop
there's no bishop e7
[Music]
i'm realizing i also have queen f4
queen f4 ideas
maybe even rook lifting
i still want to play this move
eventually
is this a this isn't the last round
it's a penultimate round
okay
up about two minutes on the clock
it's funny because my opponent's name is
funny d4 man
but they've been too scared to play d4
it would be funny if black plays d4
[Music]
man
then i would play knight e4 and
[Music]
my piece of my pieces would be laughing
at the night
wow queen d6
okay here i'll take and do what i said
earlier
queen h6 of f5 i play rookie three
if queen f8 then i made in one
am i not
meeting i mean i have this move
i should start with this move
where's my meat
f6 is undefended
what is this
the general like puzzle rush type made
is you take on a seven
but f7 is defended by
too many things
well now i have time to
[Music]
ponder my options
i could take here and then take here
yeah that's probably
the simplest way to go
it's weird like i didn't see any like
better discoveries
but now the rook is happy to come in
yeah i didn't play rookie 3 there
because knight g4
that's black's plan
oh shall i do a blindfold challenge
stream every month as well
i like the idea of like doing monthly
types of streams
well it's kind of not funny that my
opponent never actually played d4
i would have liked to see d4 in the
final position
[Music]
yeah this was a pretty oh this was
actually a very mistake-free game
[Music]
uh
[Music]
licha saying i play the perfect game
oh short summary of essentialism while
games of starting now i'm actually
playing the person who won the previous
game
um
[Music]
but it's basically a book on
on this mindset
in some respect it's kind of similar to
minimalism
but it's about how to approach like
decisions and
taking on new endeavors and
it was very eye-opening i wish i could
like have time to elaborate but i should
probably stay focused here
let's play
play e6
so playing
kind of a solid queen's gamut decline
setup
e4 is
one of the main moves
knight g5 expected
pawn takes i think is also playable
i'll play knight c6
this is somewhat of a cat line of mine
it's probably more typical to have c5
included
there's some benefit when when i keep
the pawn back it covers e6
because there are situations where
as the pawn was on c5 then g6 could
become weak
in the middle game
i also develop a bit quicker here
white's taking their time
i should know i didn't take the
seemingly free pawn because
nothing in life is free also i think
there would have been some like weird
weird night move
i'm not sure about knight g5 but
i can look after the game
maybe i just trusted my opponent too
much
okay so b3
this should be too expected
idea to play a4
now i could play a4
[Music]
then maybe i can play knight b4
so unleashing against the pawn
rookie one is probably coming
i was thinking bishop c5
just trying to activate
as much as i can
yeah i have a pretty aggressive setup
it's hard for white to remove the knight
and the knight ties down the queen to
defending c2
if c3 i play knight t3 and fork all the
things
not to mention there might be some
simple moves
like here here here
95
looks aggressive but i think it's just
more prophylactic
preventing knight g4
wondering if i can play this
the c3 i just take
and if takes takes
takes six knight of three i've taken win
c2 what is this
i lucy seven
[Music]
i win e4
[Music]
it feels wrong trading off the dark
squared bishop
let's do it
because i i was optimistic about
exploiting f2
but i think this is justified because i
get initiative
white has some loose things mainly the
knight and the bishop
if we trade then dark squares on the
queens are weak
so if takes takes knife three i have
queen c3
c2 is hit or d is coming
wow i didn't see that move
so if i take knight takes takes a queen
let's say rook takes knight c2
rook c1
might be similar to the other line
i'm looking at the idea of rook d8 in
that line and then after takes takes
takes like rook d1
bishop f1 bishop a6
and then there's knight d3
and pesky b2 knight
i think i should start by taking the
bishop though
[Music]
how do i take the queen it's committal
oh let's do it because then i have an
option which pawn to take
i guess white has the option which rook
to take with
yeah that was expected
so what i was just calculating is knight
c2 rook c1 rook d8
oh i can't even play rook d1 because
knight d1
very pesky knight on b2
and if i take this way
then there's takes takes rook d7
[Music]
but then rook c8
or even knight d5
ah there's a funny line takes takes
takes
rook d7 knight d5 c4 knight ef6
trapping the rook
oh but then takes takes takes
i think i start by taking
and it looks covered on d7 by the night
yeah probably just rook c8
so takes takes rook deciding rook c8
i'll be up a clean pawn
and if i get the chance i would like to
play rook d8
oh another idea if rook
d7 i can play f6
knight moves and then um okay eventually
e5 but r7
just cover the seventh
that's probably the way to go
rook c8 would cover things but
this is a bit more active
still a question knight f3 rook f7 rook
never mind
ooh
okay my knight's supported so i don't
have to move it
but if i play this
yeah let's play this
oh there's this move
it might be oh wait no wait what's going
on
i thought i was giving back a pawn but
rook d4 i take
and then takes
white's giving a rook
okay
that was a slightly confusing line
shawarma says there should be a drinking
game
oh drinking game there is a funny line
[Music]
oh yeah there were a lot of funny lines
this game
but you would drink tea so you just
become more calm
more times i say there's a funny line
yeah a lot of lines there hey i crossed
2600
i clinch first two
so starting off the new year undefeated
on
draw on
also on
[Music]
how do i convey that i'm also like
didn't have any draws
i guess undefeated
unstalemated
underdrawed
oh unbeaten and undrawn
so some game's still going
um i do want to address the question
from the previous game
why
i didn't take on e4
so first of all if i take with bishop
i don't think this is good because takes
if we throw in the queen tray and then
takes her some knight d2 and
okay there's f5 but
this diagonal is kind of painful for me
and if knight takes
actually maybe i can get away with this
i move like 91 i have knight c5
this has happened twice in masters play
white's play knight e5
and then knight d6
oh wow takes takes queen f3
and then
white won this game
[Music]
so 95
i should know this because this is like
part of my opening repertoire
i've just always played knight c6
wait knight takes e4
yeah 95 wow i learned something new it's
actually a cool opening trap
it's not super intuitive
but the point is
yeah black wants to move the knight away
to the fend
but takes takes queen f3
too much power
and i assume f5 queen h5
eventually
okay white can throw in taking
a queen h5 and g6 or takes
okay interesting to know
so
even though the tournament isn't
officially over
uh
i've
yeah i've clinched first i think i'll
wrap it up for the people
watching in the future on youtube
if you've made it this far
congratulations
say hi to twitchchat
become a part of twitchchat
twitch say hi to youtube
or say bye to youtube
and youtube commenters
say hi to twitch
let me know in the comments what your
favorite game was in this video
and stay tuned for more content
in 2022